cuanto me debe entonces nos están
preguntando por la longitud del segmento
b y aquí tenemos el punto a y aquí
tenemos el punto b el punto a está en
menos 5 el punto b está en 1 entonces
básicamente nos están preguntando por la
distancia de menos 5 a 1 y hay varias
formas de pensar en esto podríamos
simplemente hacer la resta por ejemplo
hacer uno menos menos cinco que sería
uno más cinco o sea seis también
podríamos literalmente contar la
distancia contar uno dos tres cuatro
cinco seis sale entonces ahí nos da otra
vez seis o bien podríamos ver que de
menos cinco a cero se recorre en cinco y
luego de cero a uno se recorre otro y
por lo tanto en total entre a y b hay
una distancia de seis entonces aquí le
voy a poner seis muy bien siguiente
pregunta vamos a hacer algunos más
cuánto mide cede a pues ahora está bien
fácil aquí que 12 y aquí quedó de
entonces pues la distancia simplemente
es 1 vale entonces aquí nos queda 1
muy bien siguiente pregunta cuánto mide
de a d
ok este está un poco más interesante
entonces pues podemos contar por ejemplo
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
entonces sería 8 le voy a poner 8 o
bueno también podemos ver que de menos 5
a 0 son 5
luego de 0 a 3 pues son otros 3 entonces
5 con 3 son 8 o bien también lo que
podríamos hacer es restar si tomar el 3
restarle menos 53 menos menos cinco es
35 que nos da 8